[Music]
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] em
[Music]
today is friday
you know what friday is it's bonehead of
the week
in the second hour of the tony michaels
podcast thanks for joining us here
noon eastern 11 central ninth pacific
every single weekday
on youtube twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the minus touch
facebook page
things are getting nuclear
all the domestic terrorists have lost
their minds this morning the party of
the domestic terrorists the american
first nazi party this is this is um
folks
they're really digging their heels in
to a situation that is not going to go
well for them i do believe
i just don't [ __ ] believe that the
fbi the department of justice and
merrick garland
decided to issue a search warrant go
into mar-a-lago search his private
office and melania's closet
for nuclear
related classified documents
national security documents
i just don't believe that they were like
ah we're gonna go [ __ ] with him when
they could have [ __ ] with him in so
many different ways
and this was the issue
this clearly was a situation where
whoever the informant is and whoever the
agents are at the fbi office
uh the the field office
went to this judge and this magistrate
said hey
yeah if this is real where the [ __ ] this
guy can't have these things because
folks it's not just about him having
them
and mike turner the republican that
[ __ ] [ __ ] pointed it out this
morning in their little their little
cheeto dust knee pad press conference
which makes it even worse on them
a lot of this footage that's coming from
this press conference this morning where
they're getting on their knees and
giving fellatio to the cheeto dust manga
king
is gonna hurt them badly very badly
they're stoking stochastic terrorism
they're making the fbi as if it's some
kind of rogue government agency
rogue law enforcement they don't back
the blue anymore because the blue is
coming after them
i believe that's why a lot of these
people in congress are calling to behead
the fbi
and the department of justice just ban
it
because they're coming after them
it seems to be more and more clear
that's what's happening
after
jeffrey clark john eastman and now a
member of congress scott perry's cell
phone has been taken
i think there and and now that this
search warrant was issued
by a magistrate a federal magistrate
they now know they're now freaking out
that local law enforcement knew about
this it seems the narrative
in the far right is that desantis knew
about this and desantis is absolutely
quiet and there's one thing we know
about desantis is he does not shut his
mouth
this is getting real very quickly and
this afternoon we're going to hopefully
i actually think he might still obstruct
he said on truth social release release
the receipt release the warrant or
whatever the [ __ ] he said release the
documents now witch hunt whatever the
[ __ ] he's saying over there on fraud
social
he's freaking out is what he's do i mean
absolutely freaking out
if you have a true social account a
fraud social account you should go over
and check it out holy [ __ ] i cannot even
believe that this person
was someone that we as a country
collectively decided would be a good
idea that he was in control of [ __ ]
especially nuclear codes and nuclear
arsenal information holy [ __ ]
because this morning folks it it appears
that the republicans
have been weaponized this morning by
donald trump
to protect the fact that yeah there was
evidence they did collect [ __ ] and
there's a reason why they went and took
it
and it ain't because it existed in his
presence
as mike turner so dumbly pointed out
this morning that donald trump knows
this stuff in his head
that's not that's not a very good case
mike turner that's actually a really
horrible case for what you're trying to
say
because the long and short of it is if
it's really in his head and he knows
this information what does he need the
documents for other than to give them
away which he's not going to give
anything away
or sell them
that's starting to be the talk and ron
desantis is quiet
zip not a word
that's bad that's really bad for donald
trump
that's horrible
if ron desantis isn't going to say
anything because ron desantis if he was
briefed on this if if we find out ron
desantis knew about this search warrant
knew what it was
was pervy to why they were going to to
do this search which the warrant's going
to show us that the receipt is going to
show us that
then ron desantis knew that donald trump
was absolutely [ __ ]
because if he was trying to sell nuclear
information about our nuclear
capabilities
two foreign leaders are anyone really
for that matter but especially foreign
powers
um
that's espionage
that's that that border lines on
espionage
and this morning if that's the talk if
that really is what has happened here
um we're talking about something totally
separate in january 6 folks then the
treason he committed on our country on
january 6 we're talking about a totally
separate [ __ ] issue
this is a totally separate crime
this isn't even in the same goddamn
universe
other than he tried to use his pr
presidency to gain power in the january
6
case and then this nuclear arsenal
information national security
breach
espionage if you're selling secrets
about our nuclear arsenal
national security information are you
[ __ ] serious
holy [ __ ]
and this morning the republicans are all
over the map
the the party of the domestic terrorists
are in disarray and it's not surprising
really because they can't figure it out
and the reason why they can't figure it
out is because it's donald trump
they're trying to defend the in
the indefensible
they can't find a spot to stake their
flag here
i mean first it was all it was all it's
all political it's all political
yesterday it was all they planted
evidence they planted evidence now this
morning it's oh well that nuclear
information the president has the right
to have it if he secures it properly
so why is the fbi so concerned
they must be corrupt so now we're back
around to the politicization which folks
honestly us as voters and us as the
government because we are the government
it's our country it's our government
it's our vote we put these people in
power no one but us
so we are the government we should
politicize the ever-loving [ __ ] out of
this you go damn right just like i say
about everything else they're always
like oh the democrats politicize
everything well they don't do it very
well
i'll do it i don't give a [ __ ]
i could give two shits less and i think
you should too we should politicize the
[ __ ] out of this
to save our democracy that's what we
should do
but this afternoon after the show is
over we're gonna see these documents
released or we'll see trump block these
documents being released
either way is horrible
horrible for donald trump and horrible
horrible for the party of domestic
terrorists
that's their that's their
self-definition
is they are all domestic terrorists
so
we're going to find out this afternoon
what is going to be
the best worst idea they have
he has said on fraud social he has put
out statements that he is gonna let them
release them he is not going to block
them
i find that hard to believe
he's blocked everything else
ever in court or tried his damnedest
and apparently yesterday he was trying
to get lawyers together to see if they
could
prevent the doj from ever releasing
these documents ever in the history of
ever ever
so something leads me to believe that
him making a statement on true social
that he's willing to let these documents
get out in the open is [ __ ] i think
he blocks him at the very last moment
which i actually think is worse on him
it's worse on him because he's
his allies and he has been screaming
release that release the documents
really their perfect doc it's a perfect
one perfect warrant absolutely great
warrant it's the best warrant you've
ever seen
they're not going to release these
documents
i have a feeling he's going to block
this or try to block it now he's only
going to be able to block it for so long
before we find out the truth
and rather charges come from this search
warrant and what they found or what they
didn't find
we'll
we are a long way off from that probably
i know it seems like you should slap the
the cold steel on his wrist
but at this point that's not exactly how
this works
because if there is more nefarious stuff
than just him having them and the talk
of that he might have been
releasing them or giving them away or
more
sinister selling them to world powers
other world powers other foreign
governments other foreign actors other
foreign agents holy [ __ ]
you know in this country before
we've actually executed people
for exactly that that that claim that
charge
a lot of people are pointing out the
rosenbergs this morning
that this country executed them for
selling nuclear secrets
over a half century ago
espionage is not something that the
united states [ __ ] around with
at all
and we shouldn't
we should not [ __ ] around with espionage
treason sedition
or any sort of conspiracy in thereof
but we watch as the domestic terrorist
caucus
in the house
this morning comes out in front of the
microphone so we're gonna watch plenty
of this video we got bonehead of the
week in the second hour but we're going
to watch some of this video now from
this press conference at the bottom of
the hour when we go to the [ __ ] list
round up because we'll do the [ __ ] list
roundup we'll round up all the tweety
tweets and trendy trends but this video
is absolutely bonkers that that's this
is where this party is
that they're willing to throw away their
entire party which you know again it's
at least stephonic it's mike turner it's
a bunch of people that probably
probably have a lot to do with january 6
probably have a lot of criminal
liability in the first place and that's
what the cheeto dust mobster is holding
over their head to go out and march in
front of a microphone and act like this
is all normal
that a former president united states
has
nuclear arsenal information national
security information locked away and is
safe
because
you know it is that's where he wants it
to be or some [ __ ] i don't know maybe he
had it in melania's underwear drawer i'm
not sure i couldn't say
it's hard to tell
who knows
and he complained about having an extra
lock
all i could think of last night is like
you know those little diary
that the the kids have and and they got
the little heart lock the heart lock
padlock on them
uh yeah that's probably about all he
could afford anyways
and then they're complaining this
morning also in this press conference
that oh well hillary hillary hillary and
emails hillary and emails and hunter
biden's laptop
the fbi has hunter vines lapped up has
had it
hillary complied with the fbi
when it when it became known that she
had emails on her private server and
some of them may be deemed classified
which one of them was marked with a
lowercase c if you do remember and do
recall and the only reason why they knew
that is because hillary clinton
cooperated with the authorities to make
sure that they got those servers
donald trump has had
more than enough chances to cooperate
with authorities here but he has not
been
that's the reason why they did what they
did when they found out the information
that they found out that it was
we need to go in now and get this stuff
and no telling how many pictures were
taken
how many scans were taken of this
information that he has
and hell maybe that's the maybe that's
the reason why they went back it's
because they knew it been scanned
printed off and stuck in a safe
we don't know any of these things and we
won't know him for a while
but the fact of the matter remains when
merrick garland came out yesterday he
personally approved this
he personally approved this
and for anyone out there listening
there's been a lot of doubt on the on
the left about merrick garland and i
talked about it yesterday in my tweet
and a lot of people said oh you're
attacking the left no i'm not attacking
the left i'm attacking don winslow is
who i'm attacking
don winslow again yesterday
calling for merrick garland to to do
something about donald trump immediately
for the last year and a half almost two
years
he does something mayor garland comes
out and said i personally signed this
thing and he still
cast away the idea i don't know if
merrick garland stole don winslow's
lunch money when he was a kid or
something i have no idea
i think it's don winslow's ego getting
in the way he's blocked me on twitter so
it's hard for me to even know
but i know what he was tweeting
yesterday and what he was tweeting
yesterday is the same dribble the same
grifton ass [ __ ]
and yeah i'm gonna call out i'm gonna
call out people who are on the left
don winslow i used to
look at as someone who is pro-democracy
but he's attacking our institutions he's
attacking our democracy and there is a
difference between doubting
doubting merrick garland
and doubting rather the doj will do
something or not
and kicking democracy when it's down
and i will not stand back and watch i
don't give a [ __ ] who you are i don't
care how big your following is i don't
care how many [ __ ] books you've
written i don't give a [ __ ] how many
videos you have i don't care how much
[ __ ] how how you could tweet to
eviscerate me i don't give a [ __ ]
if you are kicking democracy while it's
down you are not the friend of democracy
and i'm gonna call it out i'm gonna
[ __ ] say something
just like i call out all the domestic
terrorists in the america first nazi
party i'm gonna call you out too
hell i've talked about tyt on here
attacking democracy kicking democracy
when it's down acting like the demo all
this is the democrats fault
lying lying to their supporters lying to
their followers lying to their listeners
lying to their viewers it's all [ __ ]
and you need you pro-democracy people
out there need to consider this
you need to consider this
this is important i mean we've watched
cnn and msnbc this last week try try to
try to frame this up as the government's
bad the government did something bad
here
and and now as we tick down to the
countdown of releasing this warrant the
media looks like dumb [ __ ]
and the reason why they look like dumb
[ __ ] is because they're always trying
to do this both side [ __ ]
because they don't want to be painted up
as liberal or biased get the [ __ ] out of
here with that [ __ ] you bias to what the
truth
you can't tell the [ __ ] truth
get out of here with that [ __ ] i
ain't putting up with it i don't give a
[ __ ] who it is
i could care less who it is
if your main goal is to kick democracy
and lady liberty while she's on her last
leg well you you are not no friend of
mine or you're not pro-democracy no
matter how much you claim it
these institutions matter
and merrick garland made that clear
yesterday in his press conference
that the attacks on the fbi and the doj
are unamerican
and they cause stochastic terrorism like
happened in cincinnati yesterday like
it's being chattered about all over
[ __ ] right-wing social media
because republican politicians are
giving them [ __ ] permission to do it
by acting like oh yeah we need to disbar
behead the fbi the fbi is corrupt the
doj is corrupt
and don winslow if you look at don
winslow's tweets
if you just go back and look at all the
merrick garland don winslow tweets that
he's put out
you will see that language show up this
morning in the domestic terrorist press
conference in the house this morning
same [ __ ] same [ __ ] same [ __ ]
yeah maybe just a little different angle
same language
same language saying it the exact same
way
saying it the exact same way
and this nonsense has been going on for
a long time
that the right and some [ __ ] on
the left
have been stoking this [ __ ]
i mean jesus christ you even have andrew
cuomo who's being probably investigated
by the fbi wanting to disband the fbi of
course he does why wouldn't you want to
disband a law enforcement agency that's
going to bring charges against you and
put you in prison possibly of course you
would want to disband them
why wouldn't you i mean you'd be for
that
if they were after you of course you
would why do you think they're freaking
out about the [ __ ] 87 000 irs agents
they're freaking out about it because
the actual phones are gonna operate at
the irs now and now their rich [ __ ]
donors won't be able to skate on taxes
and get away with [ __ ] because
there'll be people doing their job the
job that they're supposed to do
overseeing our department of revenue of
the united states
not locking people in jail just just
making sure the [ __ ] shop is open for
crying out loud
really ridiculous [ __ ] that we would
fight against efficient government
especially efficient revenue service
that delivers us the revenue
so that way we can actually do the thing
called i don't know government
it's really boneheaded [ __ ]
america collectively needs to pluck its
head out of its own ass
here
and this morning i'm gonna try to show
you
how we
how we help the
i can't even believe that we're in this
position i i have to call them the party
of the domestic terrorists because that
that's what they are that's what they
are
they're using the same lame as it saying
same exact language
that timothy mcveigh was doing for the
oklahoma city bombing
it's right out of the turner diaries
the same [ __ ] the same exact [ __ ]
they're not even talking about big
government anymore it's not even big
government anymore
it's not even old they'll come take your
guns you know who who is they
they're way past way beyond that
way beyond that
and we watched yesterday as someone who
who
let these domestic terrorists get inside
their little p brain
and go to an fbi uh office in cincinnati
with a nail gun and an ar-15 it resulted
in him being dead
of course it did
he's deranged
and they deranged him the domestic
terrorist the american first nazi party
the republicans the gqp
the moglodites
a nail gun
he thought a nail gun was going to work
against the fbi that would be a good
idea
it's a [ __ ] out of their gourds they
are
and they they've led them down this path
folks
and i'm not saying these people don't
have fault of course they do
their delusion and derangement there's
been plenty of off-ramps here and the
republican party have taken none of them
absolutely [ __ ] none of them
so they own this and we should make them
own this
i'm excited
today
about i don't mean to skip
i seem bipolar there huh i'm excited
today about the bonehead of the week you
guys voted for bonehead of the week
me and gabe have talked about doing the
poll like this for a long time but boy
this week um every single day the cheeto
dust mobster grandpa booby pants has
stepped in it every single day like
every one of them boom boom boom boom
and we thought it was a perfect week to
rig the vote
so i don't know if you um if you went
over and looked at the bonehead of the
weak pole
well we rigged it oh yeah goddamn we
rigged it because we want to talk about
it we want
we want to make it exclusive
because he's not just a bonehead of the
week he's not just the bonehead of the
year he's the bonehead of the of the
century
of the world of history holy [ __ ]
and i'm sure this afternoon he's gonna
step in it even heavier
as he blocks this
release from the court this unsealing of
these documents and that's my guess i
think he'll block it because he's saying
he he wants to release them right
he actually doesn't want to release them
because he knows the ramifications
we'll see we'll we'll get to we'll get
to know
what what they were after
to some degree because some of it may be
redacted because it's classified
but the courts are going to unseal the
documents today at 3 p.m um they've
ordered them at 3 p.m as long as donald
trump does not try to object or block it
and i'm excited about it because i'm
sure he's going to he's gonna pull the
biggest boneheaded move
he's gonna block it and then he's gonna
really get on his fraud social and he's
gonna freak out just keep freaking out
freaking out freaking out and then the
republicans are gonna have to tuck tail
and run again
because they're setting this up this
morning you're going to see this video
they're setting this up for these
documents to be unsealed that's what
they're trying to do they're trying to
get ahead of that cycle this morning
with this domestic terrorist press
conference
where they're condoning
a former government official that we
elected in our office of the president
of possibly stealing
maybe giving away and probably more than
likely selling those nuclear secrets and
that national security information
to a foreign power
holy [ __ ] they're defending that in
front of a [ __ ] microphone in our
goddamn capital
and there's people going yeah woo defend
him what are you talking about this is
espionage if he is actually selling
these [ __ ] which i floated this
out that i would not be surprised if we
found out he was selling it
why would he take it
what the [ __ ] does he care
he doesn't give a [ __ ] about a nuclear
arsenal or national security information
he doesn't give a [ __ ]
he doesn't care about national security
information the only reason why he'd
care about it if it was a payday that's
it and
on top of that
we've watched as the saudis have dumped
billions of dollars into jared kushner
his son-in-law's pocket
after private meetings with the saudis
hmm
and not just a few weeks after his first
wife's death where he buried her
bedminster the saudis showed up at
bedminster to hold their little golf
tournament
and all the domestic terrorists went and
got on the got on the balcony and
cheered with donald trump
you had tucker carlsey and marjorie
taylor green than the likes
hmm
i don't know
i don't know what's gonna happen here
but boy
he was the reality tv show president
and he is going to be the reality tv
show ex-president jesus christ
and stay up to date stay right here
every single weekday monday through
friday for two full hours on youtube
twitter and twitch don't forget to
follow our youtube channel please
subscribe to the tony michaels podcast
here on youtube
we also simulcast from the midas touch
facebook page but don't forget don't
forget today's bonus of the week and you
can vote for bonehead of the week on
twitter at tonymichaelspod go over there
and follow us at tonymichaelspod you can
also download bonehead of the week after
we get done recording it we actually cut
it out in and of itself and we download
it every single sunday on every
directory apple spotify google your
favorite directory while you're there
downloading bone of the week on sunday
and while you're playing all of our
other episodes because you love them
even if you watch them here you can
listen to them over there
there's no need not to double dip
but while you're doing that please leave
us a review on on your favorite
directory that is very important to us
it helps us out
we much appreciate we welcome all the
new audience members that we have
we're very excited to have you
very excited so stay tuned because we're
gonna do the [ __ ] list roundup before
bone end of the week right after these
messages stay right here don't go
anywhere
we'll be right back mark
60 seconds this is the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing nancy pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi i'm paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket i've got
you covered pardon blanket specifically
works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on january 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too pardon blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the usa don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual parting's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the tony
michaels podcast
welcome
welcome welcome back to the show thanks
for sticking around
this is tony michaels
tony michaels podcast
welcome all the new listeners you're in
for a treat we have reached a part of
the show where we round up all the
tweety tweets
and the trendy trends that's right we
surf twitter right here on the joni
michaels podcast we gotta stay up to
date on this stuff we cannot let our
guard down with these [ __ ] these
domestic terrorists this america first
nazi party
we have to be on our guard and the way
that we stay on our guard post is not
look away we cannot look away we have to
make sure we know exactly what they're
saying because they're planning they're
scheming right out loud they're doing it
this morning in this domestic terrorist
caucus this press conference that the
that the gqp of the house
the chi the chitollini's the moglodites
gave in the house of representative our
house of representatives they were
talking in the microphones this morning
they're already laying the groundwork of
what is gonna happen this afternoon when
donald trump this is either released or
he blocks it
i think they're counting on it getting
released but i think he's gonna block it
what do you think
i actually think he's not gonna let this
happen he knows it's bad now my personal
opinion is is that if he blocks it
that's worse that's way worse that means
he's hiding something the country's
gonna see that look we have come a long
way in the last three four months in
this country of how this country views
donald trump
and what their opinion of his of him is
and i've said this many many times the
biggest fraud that he has wrought on our
country is that he has this large
massive percentage of support which i
don't believe he does
i actually believe it's a smaller
percentage than what we believe that are
that are loyal to him it's a large
number of people don't don't get it
twisted it's a large large number of
people but percentage-wise it's a very
small small number when you're talking
about loyal supporters and that is who
they're screaming the dog whistle at
this morning because they want
he wants those that those supporters to
save him just like he wanted them on
january 6th and he kept saying oh
january 6 is going to be wild come to
the capitol we're going to have a grand
old time overthrowing the government
he's doing the same thing here he knows
he's in trouble
the republicans know he's in trouble
they know they're in trouble that's why
they're saying behead the fbi
i guess paul gosar said kill the fbi or
some [ __ ] this morning yeah that's a
great that's a great message paul goes
are you [ __ ] traitor
and that really is the story that we
have and we're gonna continue to have
this folks this is not going away
anytime soon this election that we have
coming is the most important election of
our democracy's life
and as soon as it's over as soon as
those ballots are counted cast and
certified the next election will be the
most important election in our
democracy's lifetime these people are
not just going to slither under their
rocks anytime soon
he's given them permission and boy do
they think they got power over us
when they hold governorships like ron
desantis in florida like greg abbott and
texas
they think they're going to win some of
these senate seats like in georgia
pennsylvania ohio arizona
they want to win the governorship in
arizona and we cannot we cannot relent
we cannot stop we cannot stop fighting
for our democracy and our way of life
it is in danger here they want to take
it away from us
now
or am i always a fan of law enforcement
am i always a fan of the department of
justice or fbi no
i can be critical of the fbi and the
department of justice
when we need to be we can call them out
we can we can be very very very
strategic
in making sure that they're held in
account
but this call to absolutely dismantle
our democracy and our federal law
enforcement agency that has kept our
democracy safe for for for over a
hundred years
this is really [ __ ] stupid this is
really [ __ ] dumb it's dangerous as
[ __ ]
now we would allow that we would allow
these domestic terrorists to undermine
our institutions and our democracies
that that will protect us from them
and that's why they want them torn down
because it is a backstop that's the
protection that we have from them the
domestic terrorists and i i'm i didn't
make up the domestic terrorist thing
i didn't i i mean they are
but they self-proclaimed that [ __ ] down
at their nuremberg rally in texas the
first nazi rally that's been held here
since 1939
when the first america first rally was
held in 1939
and they called george washington some
america's first fascist and there were
actual nazis nazi flags they were proud
of it back in 1939 of the america first
nazi party
and they're embracing it now
white christian nationalism nazism
the america first nazi party the
domestic terrorist caucus
is running rough shot all over our
democracy and we
shall not and we should not
and we cannot let them let them get away
with it and the way that we do that is
engage in our democracy we have to have
strategic outrage we have to
you have to stay pissed
this this
this idea
that we have to be tolerant of
intolerance is absolute 100 [ __ ] we
do not have to be tolerant of
intolerance
to human beings or our democracy
or equality and equity they are
intolerant of equality and equity and we
do not have to be tolerant of that
intolerance that is not something we
have to do we do not have to act like
it's some kind of different world view
[ __ ] no it isn't
it's not just some other world view
it's a threat to our countrymen
our citizens
our way of life
rather you're black brown female male
lgbt it doesn't matter
they will come after you
that's what they're saying they're
they're they're yelling it out loud
they're telling you what they want you
to hear
they're telling you who they are
and how they want to tear apart our
[ __ ] country
and they said it this morning they said
it this morning they want to they want
to get rid of the doj and the fbi so
they don't investigate them
because that's a backstop
that protects our country from them the
domestic terrorists we watched it
yesterday
can you imagine can you imagine
yesterday
if if we disbarred and got rid of the
fbi and doj
haley may have went to a local law
enforcement agency
because they're not just going to stop
they're not going to stop at law
enforcement at the fbi
they're going to start putting they're
going to start putting mogalodites and
mogula
jurisdictions and they're going to grow
those jurisdictions
that's what they'll do jesus christ ron
desantis is doing it down in florida
he's taking elected law enforcement
agents
state attorneys
who are poised with with charging and
indicting and prosecuting crimes
in south florida
and he's suspending that person who is
elected by the people
usurping real [ __ ] democracy stealing
the vote away from those people in that
district because ron desantis just
doesn't think that that attorney is
fascist enough for him
they'll do the same thing with sheriff's
departments state police
oh you're not fascist enough out you go
we want only fascist that's what they're
pissed off about really here with this
fbi thing
is they're going after the manga king
king cheetah leading the orange
mussolini jesus grandpa poopy pants the
cheeto dust mobster they're going after
him that's what really pisses them off
that's what really pisses them off
because they know they [ __ ] know
folks they [ __ ] know
if the fbi and the doj can round up that
[ __ ] they're in real big trouble
really big trouble
well let's not waste much more time
because i also have you got to see this
clip this clip is [ __ ] delicious
folks it's it is it is one of the most
delicious clips i have seen in the last
few days i'm not kidding you it it oh
man it's
whoo
it's the greatest lip ever this week i
believe i mean until donald trump gets
out in front of a microphone and starts
speaking or gets on the phone and starts
speaking about how he's guilty of [ __ ]
with this search warrant
but i'm telling you i'm telling you
this raid that happened
does not compare to this video clip
of eric boland and and john bolton so
hang around with the shitless roundup
because we're gonna start surfing the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends
right now let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the [ __ ] list
welcome welcome welcome back to the [ __ ]
list roundup where we round up all the
tweety tweets and the trendy trends like
i said i got a lot of video to get to
today holy moly uh let's go straight
away to this uh john bolton video i
can't help it i love this i love this
clip
i hate john bolton i do not like eric
bolan and i love to watch them eat their
own sandwich and eat each other this is
fantastic and this is on newsmax of all
places this is fantastic folks
these people are completely [ __ ] when
you have lost when you have lost john
bolton
when you have lost john bolton
to trumpet your your weird [ __ ] gop
old republican talking points for
foreign policy when you've lost him oh
[ __ ]
it's it's getting it's getting rough
let's watch oral could you think that
we're safer now than we were under
president trump when he was willing to
put missiles into eric looks really he
so so here's the cr here's the aim of
this
john bolton has basically said yeah
we're way safer under biden than we were
under trump which everyone knows that
everyone knows that
everyone knows that we're back we're
back to a place where we can actually
say our foreign our foreign
diplomats are in place i mean think
about this when when we were under trump
we didn't have a lot of our diplomats
even in place in these countries we had
no idea what was going on in these
regions we couldn't even operate
in any kind of political discourse with
any kind of nation because our state
department was absolutely obliterated
around the world
safer my [ __ ] ass
so john bolton's trying to lay out some
facts here which it is really it is
really something to watch john bolton
to watch john bolton pull out facts it
really is something but eric bolden's
sweaty he's pissed off he's very
agitated here well let's watch syrian
air bases with russians on the base
what's going on here licking his lips
he's sweaty you notice how he's kind of
orange you notice that watch john bolton
just [ __ ] eat his lunch oh this is
again i couldn't think of any other word
but delicious
he didn't understand because he didn't
understand fundamentally much of
anything about international affairs
john bolton's like he's a [ __ ] dummy
i wish i wish we could get some people
just to say that [ __ ] right i mean if we
could get in the mainstream media people
who talk like me who say it just like me
just like you
he's a [ __ ] dummy
he's an idiot he doesn't know [ __ ] from
shinola what the [ __ ] are you talking
about about foreign policy that we're
safer
under that stupid stooge than we are
under someone who actually understands
even just a little bit of foreign policy
i mean if you go back and you rewind to
2008 when barack obama picked joe biden
he picked joe biden do you remember why
he picked joe biden specifically i mean
it was political obviously it was a
political campaign they were trying to
win an election a lot of people were
really worried about barack obama's
experience or lack thereof in foreign
policy so he picked joe biden
he that's why he did it
he picked uncle joe because uncle joe
knew just as good or anyone in the
senate
and in politics in general about foreign
policy
and here here eric bolden is trying to
gas like john bolton
that somehow who who by the way who by
the way was the us ambassador of the
united nations a horrible one under bush
he was also on the national he was also
national security advisor of trump
so he was right there in the room with
this [ __ ] he knows he knows how
dumb trump is
so let's listen his decisions were not
based on a coherent philosophy or
and this is
right here this set of facts just this
thing his [ __ ] his decisions are not
based on a coherent philosophy that
describes trump
100 across the board not just with his
national security not just with foreign
policy not with domestic policy not with
health care or education or the
coronavirus or anything else the
[ __ ] has the inability the
inability to make decisions on a
coherent set of facts it's only what he
feels it's only what the television tube
is telling him jesus christ john bolton
i it's it's it's amazing to watch him
drop these little nuggets of of truth
we're coherent we were safer
he kept under donald trump
world leaders he signed a deal with the
taliban now here we go here we go so
they're going to start talking about
taliban in afghanistan and and john
bolton is pointing out why we had such a
[ __ ]
nightmare when joe biden had to
implement donald trump's plan that he
negotiated with the taliban which really
[ __ ] pisses john bolton off because
john bolton would know
would like to just absolutely eliminate
and kill anyone who claims their taliban
and he would like to do it whether it's
illegal or not
because he's a [ __ ] warmonger
but
it is beautiful to watch this part i'm
telling you this is a delicious piece of
tape here and the reason why is because
you can use this same strategy this same
john bolton strategy on your uncle earl
when you're talking to him about oh
donald trump made a safer
oh donald trump was better it was better
under trump you can use this same
[ __ ] strategy right here just watch
this tape a few times take the talking
points of john bolton those few facts
and [ __ ] dump them on your uncle earl
or on your co-host gabe sanchez gabe how
are you
i'm good you're a little shitless but
i'm glad you're here um have you have
you watched this clip
i did yeah yeah just we're getting to
the part here where john bolton has to
lay out who actually negotiated with the
terrorist organization the taliban
a lot of people tend to forget that
detail eric poland it just almost
explodes here watch this and kept them
on their back feet they didn't know
where he was coming from and united made
us safer i mean can you he had president
deal with the taliban
from afghanistan
i'm surprised they didn't cut them off
here honestly yeah they're like and up
looks like looks like that's all the
time with the bull lost watch the
connection whoops
i mean i'm really surprised they didn't
because he is eric boland is digging a a
wider deeper hole here when he when he
starts to really talk about uh
afghanistan and when he really starts to
blame it on biden because this is really
stupid stuff i believe that the
republican party this is another thing
we can hang around their neck but
there's so many things that we're going
to lose sight of what what they d what
they really did if they were going to
show this clip to a bunch of republicans
they would say up bolton is is [ __ ]
woke and he's on the left he got woke my
ass like like it makes it actually gives
me a little
i feel a little upset to my stomach when
i find when i find satisfaction that
john bolton can actually talk about you
know a few facts within a two-minute
period you know he doesn't lie his ass
off and gas like the [ __ ] out of you in
a two-minute period that's actually a
story admit to uh you know uh
planning a coup in other countries right
successful would you like well hold on
let's not skip over that detail right uh
well i mean let's face it this clip here
is a [ __ ] sandwich eating another [ __ ]
sandwich oh yeah yeah i mean there's i
mean
pieces of [ __ ] oh absolutely well but
but the but the pure simple facts are is
this is on newsmax right
and a lot of people who who
i mean if you remember when trump picked
john bolton everyone's like yeah woohoo
yeah yeah
we're gonna really gonna kick some ass
now we're really gonna kick some ass now
as uh as well as soon as because i think
there's something interesting about
bolton like he writes a book right and
then the right goes oh no this is uh you
know this is unfair and this is not true
and all this stuff
bolton has that interview with uh was it
jake tapper right mm-hmm yeah where he
admits that he planted coo or plotted
coups in other countries right and he
kind of says it in a way like i'm really
good at plotting right because what he
was trying to say was trump is not smart
enough right to plan his own coup which
i think is a funny way of going about it
because you're like
wait if you say this then either the
trumpers go
yeah he didn't plan the coup or
someone's like wait are you calling
trump dumb he could totally plan a coup
right trump on the other would be like
uh i planned the best coups only only
the the most i mean the greatest it was
fabulous right
it was a fabulous coup you know so i i
think it's an interesting tactic that he
had at least during that interview which
is like you [ __ ] on trump for something
that is illegal
and say oh he's not competent enough to
actually do this and then you get the
trumpers plus trump to be like no i
could totally pull this off i wanted
you know so it's a it's a very
interesting tactic but either way these
pieces are these guys are both pieces of
[ __ ] oh yeah well i love this [ __ ]
sandwich eating the sich jam it's
actually i love it let's let's let's
finish watching them eat each other here
it's it's great they were right you know
what made us less safe is when biden
pulled us out of afghanistan
and now there's trump's
taliban tells us back off don't kill
al-qaeda oh my god are you out of your
mind same thing they wouldn't have done
under donald trump no oh who cut out the
deal eric
who cut the deal who delivered the deal
no no no trump see i love that too is he
can't deliver who delivered who
who put in the order for pizza who
delivered the pizza right right right it
doesn't it it still showed up like the
pizza why is the anchovies on my pizza
why are the anchovies it's the delivery
guy's fault it's the delivery guys they
delivered it right that [ __ ] on there
like you ordered this [ __ ] pizza
and it was delivered as a [ __ ] pizza the
guy who put in the order
should not be you know uh should be the
one bling not the guy who delivered what
was already put in as an order oh my god
these people let's let's finish this it
gets even better i don't know how but it
gets better what would trump have done
remember sir no he did not he absolutely
did not he did eric you don't know what
you're talking about he wanted everybody
out ideal to do exactly
no he did not he absolutely did not he
did eric you don't know what you're
talking about everybody out here
ambassador ambassador bastard you know i
mean don bolton us bastard
sounds good to me you former us bastard
to the united nations i'm good with that
if i ever had john bolton on i'd
actually we could make that his uh his
title on the thing i would do that yeah
i would have john bolton
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah let's i'd love to eat
your lunch
it reminds me of like have you ever seen
uh between two ferns with zach
galvanakis yeah and he'll misspell
someone's name right right because like
it's like oh and how it phonetically
spells out right and so that's what i
think this moment is like you know john
boltan
and it would say u.s bastard u.s yeah
former you yeah
bastard bastard to the united nations
that's right oh my god leave 2500 until
we have a smooth trade he did not
look he said that after he cut the deal
the deal cut us down to zero that's what
trump wanted he wanted everybody out the
record on that is completely clear over
time biden pulled them out well with
americans still there the best read the
deal
pompeo that's the other thing that
people forget about is is [ __ ] pompeo
is there you know with the photo op with
the
your hands shake your hands i'm like oh
how many taliban prisoners you guys want
what how many are going to swamp right
now
and nobody nobody remembers that part of
the deal they're always like joe biden
pulled out early and now the country was
taken over by the taliban and it's like
you do realize that we made an agreement
to
to do this right
we wanted these people out for years
we've been there for 20 [ __ ] years
right
no no success other than the deaths of
americans and citizens in afghanistan
well also like afghanistan is a very the
way that their governments work are
their localized their local
governments that have their own power
over each other so if you're going to
say hey this whole country we're now
going to create a democracy good [ __ ]
luck right not only is the terrain
geography difficult to get across
but also the way that the local
pockets that are ruled by each other
there is no way there was no way you
would have to eliminate all of them or
get them to agree that this is the new
way to go forward and it's just
difficult we learned that over 20 years
that it was we were unable to
successfully create a democracy there
because of how the country is laid out
and how it's been ruled
you know you're just making local deals
but not everyone agrees with the other
local deal so
that's why we ended up having to be like
it's a lost cause like we're not going
to make any development here
and we have to get out you know sooner
than later because pull out pull out
early right right yeah you're assessing
the collateral damage like if i stay for
another 10 years can i convert this
country into democracy this country that
we went into illegally because we were
going for wmds that were never there in
the first place
speaking of pulling out early i almost
this guy mike turner i know who this
[ __ ] is but i wish his mom would hear
his dad would have pulled out early
jesus christ this guy
speaking of pulling out early
this guy this morning these domestic
terrorists came up on stage to defend
donald trump it is clear that they're
trying to capture the narrative before
what happens uh at 3 p.m today eastern
time we know gabe that the the court
have the ability if trump does not block
them to release this and the receipt oh
absolutely because he said yesterday he
wasn't so you know he's going to oh and
it's probably going to be at the very
last minute that he's going to block
because everyone's going to be
anticipating and then he's going to say
oh i blocked him because they're corrupt
or hunter biden's laptop or something i
don't know because right now i mean
remember what they said even christina
bob his attorney
made
the accusation that the fbi was planting
evidence
at mar-a-lago which is the only reason
you ever bring that up is if you're like
oh [ __ ] they're going to find something
real they're getting oh yeah there's
going to be a lot of shits going on
we've already heard the nuclear dock
like the nuclear uh documents that were
classified so wait wait is it nuclear or
nuclear nuclear
like a nucleus nuclear
it's it's nuclear i think it's nuclear
but having classified documents that are
that are uh breeze over how i say
nuclear
i'll breeze over this oh okay so is
important these are these are important
things if we if we need like a sesame
street like today's today's word of the
day is nuclear
the letter n yeah
but i i what i what i find interesting
here is the fact that you know they
they're making this very bold
accusation which is the fbi came in and
they planted evidence yeah but that's
not what they're doing they're saying
what they're saying here in this press
conference is oh it's not a big deal
that he has this stuff right right right
so it's like two they can't [ __ ]
figure out which one you know no one no
one can figure out their their uh their
goal here because they're all because i
you know
before this happened when
when the raid or the the legal fbi
search happened right everyone's like
this is unprecedented we would never do
this to a president yeah well we've
never had a president who actually was a
[ __ ] criminal
but this is not unpred like you know you
and i and brett talked yesterday when we
were doing the the live stream of of
merrick garland's announcement the one
thing that we established was this is
not this is unprecedented for a
president right but it is not
unprecedented for the doj and the fbi
this is literally our job you did
something illegal you took something
they will come in and get it because
it's not yours as you said it is ours it
is the united states is property so we
have this group struggling to figure out
what they need to say uh unseal the
warrant no sealed the warrant right like
they're like oh [ __ ] this looks really
bad
and we don't know
if the nuclear documents
nuclear this the nuclear the nuclear
secrets
if the nuclear secrets
are the worst
we have yet to we have yet to figure
that out if those are the worst of the
worst or that's like ah we hit about a
mid-range worse well but don't you think
yeah but don't you think that uh because
it seems to be that the that the
narrative from the doj's perspective and
the fbi's perspective with the informant
and the local um
the local field office there was like
hey there was there was something that
we had to get in front of and it almost
feels like that the thing that you would
get out in front of is that he would be
passing these documents and there's no
way he's giving him away no [ __ ] way
can you convince him he's giving them to
someone he's definitely selling them but
here's the thing here's the thing i want
everyone to
to understand is i'm sure that [ __ ]
idiot has a copier somewhere in
mar-a-lago and i'm not even saying that
maybe the other reason why this is
criminal is because he may have handed
over this [ __ ] but he may have copied it
and put it in his safe or melania's
underwear drawer but
before he handed over the original
documents and he's possessing these
things even outside of his purview of of
handing over the documents there's all
kinds of scenarios here of why the fbi
and the department of justice felt and
the informant with the informant of the
information they were giving that they
felt like they needed to do this now
because i believe
yesterday when merrick garland came out
when we were watching him live and he
said three things he basically said um
you know i personally
i personally did this we are going to
unseal these documents and the
republican party needs to stop attacking
our law enforcement agencies yeah it's
basically was the thrust of his and it
was i mean how long was the it was like
three or four minutes was the max time i
mean we waited for almost 45 minutes for
him to speak for four minutes because
they were waiting for those documents to
be unsealed by the court right are to be
announced to be unsealed yeah so and
which were at the time still sealed but
i think also i i don't recall if the if
the press conference was a last-minute
thing that was announced because keep in
mind the the uh the timeline of the day
started
with the guy showing up with a nail gun
and an ar-15 stylus uh weapon in his car
yeah
and he showed up with a nail gun going
in the fbi thinking he was going to go
nail guns blazing by the way he's dead
not surprising he's [ __ ] dead
so so you look at that and you're like
oh look i could only guess it's a
[ __ ] trumper that decided he was
going to overtake the fbi building with
a [ __ ] nail gun right why would why
would some bonehead believe that in
cincinnati he could go in the visitors
you know the visitors um right you know
screening room yeah right and that's and
that's where you're going to take down
the department of justice and everything
these people man
and i want to show this video here
because they're really they're really
stoking the stochastic terrorism like
like brett was saying yesterday and
we've been saying here and we've had
dakota adams on and that's exactly like
what the highland park shooter yeah who
went to the 4th of july parade they're
stoking the stuff online and now they're
not just talking online they're stoking
it
on c-span in front of a microphone at
our capitol this is [ __ ] weird-ass
[ __ ] this has not really happened in our
country's history watch
this is mike turner by the way
does anybody
among the committee republicans have a
concern
with unsecured classified information
potentially being in a storage area in
florida so that is scott mcfarland a
friend of the show here we show his
stuff pretty direct question right
pretty easy yeah pretty easy you think
he would have the answer for this listen
anybody have a concern with that
i certainly i
the issue of the handling of classified
information is is an issue that of
course our committee deals with and that
we're very concerned with
however
a but yeah but
it's like are you concerned all those
things i just said i don't actually
believe because i can't believe it right
because what i'm about to say uh the
issue of classified information
and the tactics that are used uh in this
instance are the ones that we're very
concerned about there were a number of
options that were available to the
attorney general and the director of the
fbi yes and they had already exhausted
those to get those [ __ ] documents why
is everyone so confused about that there
was and this is why gabe i think there's
a [ __ ] copier mar-a-lago because if
you remember they had 15 boxes that they
pulled out of mar-a-lago yeah yeah the
other day they pulled 12 boxes right so
if you do the math and you kind of like
say well what if someone just made a
straight copy of all those 15 boxes and
stuck it in melania's underwear drawer
yeah yeah like that in 12 boxes it
starts to get equal i mean 15. right
like the most valuable information well
also yesterday
we were following on on truth social and
and trump was posting he was like oh you
know what uh
we if we had anything he was like if we
had it we would have given it to the
government right and it's like no that's
that's not the case because they already
asked you for it you said well i don't
know maybe i have it maybe i don't have
it then the national archives team had
to come down and collect 15 boxes i
don't i don't know what kind of like
forensic sweep they did inside
mar-a-lago but as soon as they went back
through and and and kind of went through
all of the documents or or you know
items that he had they go up looks like
we're missing
enough to fill another 12 boxes and
that's though that's the minimum that we
know that was get was was uh was
received this last time
so then
you've got this group that now we're at
27 boxes like you said that's almost
double like it's almost again 15 15.
double right
but it starts it starts to seem like
right he was like oh well they're going
to come take the [ __ ] i want to sell so
i better copy it that way i still have
captions right right but and here's the
thing we don't know if that was if the
things in those additional boxes were
just copies or they were actually
additional things that they held on to
and right so what you're saying is it
could be
that that there was
way more than what that right told him
that he could he could have totally had
on copies like good gave everything to
you guys and i would have totally helped
out if we had it
but the fact that he's on truth social
saying that and the fact that they're
like no we had to come back another time
and almost got the same number of boxes
in addition to
what the national archives originally
received tells you everything you should
know because they still had it or they
still had additional things
and now there's a big question of like
oh well there was the golf tournament
with the saudis and there was jared
kushner getting two billion and it's
like
you know i joked yesterday online to say
like oh yeah you can pick up the nuclear
codes at the ninth hole like i i don't
know
there might be there might be a little a
little uh like an icy you know an ice
cream or oh yeah or an icy stand and
then you know you gotta you gotta give
the code word right exactly
when you get down on the ground and you
like whisper into the hole and you say
whatever the code is well you know the
code he released the code yesterday he
was fundraising off the nuclear ghosts
right i was trying to figure out if that
was real or not but i couldn't get any
information from people but if that is
the case that is so [ __ ] up it is
weird well speaking of weird um watch
what chris stewart of utah um
says
is uh i i i'm not really following him
here but listen again these are people
that i have never really heard of or
right well
because the reason why is because
they're [ __ ] idiots that's why you've
never heard of their [ __ ] idiots
right but now they're putting themselves
on the national stage well i mean
someone is getting them to march out and
be domestic terrorists let's watch of
course they're gonna wonder that look
what's happened over the last five years
and look at the premise of most of your
questions
was it nuclear
was it nuclear well i mean were there
were their um
nuclear nuclear codes nuclear nuclear
codes down at mar-a-lago i don't know it
seems like that's what they're after but
listen to what he says next gabe was it
uh hey heck maybe it was aliens
what aliens are you [ __ ] ser this guy
what is he talking about i i i wanna i
want to believe that he is saying that
like it's information on aliens that
trump took with him but no but you're
giving them too much the benefit of
doubt here okay the fact that you're
willing to say maybe he's talking about
area 51 and they're about talking about
the aliens no they're trying to [ __ ]
say well i mean it's
you're you're trying to make up uh you
know this invisible or like this you
know unreal monster kind of thing it's
like look nuclear codes not so bad
aliens let's focus on the aliens guys
right like either either scenario if the
aliens [ __ ] planted the evidence
or it's area 51 stuff you know this is
men and black man these people watch way
too many [ __ ] movies i i i said on
the air the other day some people were
making fun of me some people thought it
was awesome then i was watching men in
black three but this really they watched
too many [ __ ] movies they watched too
many movies these are just movies people
right it's not real [ __ ] life it's
just i mean just like the people that
believe that biden and trump had a
face-off situation like you guys you
guys are that [ __ ] dumb oh it gets it
gets it gets just as dumb i mean he he
continues like he just didn't say the
dumbest thing this week and there's been
a lot of dumb [ __ ] this week yeah that's
the point we don't know
what that's the point we don't know no
we know of it so as soon as we do know
which would happen when the the search
warrant is released which trump will
he's totally gonna block there's only
two there is there are two outcomes here
one he releases it but they redact what
was searched for
right they well because they might they
might not be able to do anything but
reject yeah yeah but
what i'm if they unseal it and he
releases it then he's like oh look the
you know we can't talk about this
because you know but it's like well it's
not a big deal why did why was it
redacted right why is it top secret
right and then obviously the other end
is like did they redact it or did the
doj redact it and the doj could be like
yeah if anyone wants a search warrant
here you go media and it's them versus
trump or the other way is trump says
last minute no i'm not doing it because
it's just a woke life trying to
to blame me for something right that's
exactly what he's going to do
no way he's not going to do that is he
on truth social right now on fraud
social uh let's freaking out because
he's been free he freaked he was
freaking out all day yesterday all night
last night oh the other thing i wanted
to mention was the fact it was a
four or four days ago it was when when
the search happened
that
i don't know if you remember watching
this video or if you watch this video
but lara trump said look my
father-in-law as anyone knows who's been
around him a lot loves to save things
like new newspaper clippings magazine
clippings photographs and documents that
he had every authority will to take from
the white house
they tried to say that donald trump took
this stuff to [ __ ] scrapbook
like wow i mean
that's the logic it's it's so it's so
crazy because he is a [ __ ] hoarder if
you've ever seen like actual pictures of
his office and if you go back and you
and you listen to some of the uh people
talk about when the apprentice first
started happening mark burnett goes to
his office at the trump tower when he
walked in he's like oh my god this place
is a [ __ ] dump like it was it's such
a [ __ ] such a mess but they had to go
down to a flow a floor or floor or two
lower and build a whole new [ __ ]
trump office
so it didn't look like a [ __ ] dump
right because it's such a [ __ ]
you know roach infested dump speaking of
roach infested
well go ahead you asked the question
about truth social and as of thor as of
21 minutes ago he said president barack
hussein obama kept 33 million pages of
documents most of them classified
yeah yeah how many of them pertain to
nuclear word is lots
some people are saying speaking of
cockroaches saying um here's elise
stefanik um i i can't even imagine how
much her phone was ringing yesterday and
how much she had to listen to him [ __ ]
i mean she's she's been on everyone's
mind since then i was down in the toilet
here's what i believe i believe there's
something
that that they have on elise stefanik
and and it happened when she came to
washington something leads me to believe
that it has to do with like cocaine sex
orgies with madison gothorn and they
don't and and they ruined madison caught
throwing over that so that she doesn't
want to be ruined over that i don't know
i don't know i don't have any i'm just
saying that they have something over
because listen to this garbage
president donald trump is joe biden's
most likeliest political opponent in
2024 why what what is it
who
joe biden hasn't even announced he's
running yet
yeah i i mean
like i know that they're now using the
language of possible but let's get this
out there we we're not even up to the
2022 midterms
we're not right like as soon as that
happens in most states in most states
you can't even file for the 2024
election we're not even in that cycle
and joe biden has not announced neither
has donald trump so this is all nonsense
so really honestly i hope he blocks this
i hope he comes out this weekend
announces that he's running for
president i hope he goes balls deep into
this [ __ ] and in this country
[ __ ] just watch him up and dunks him
in the trash like he needs to be because
that's really what is happening here is
he's not he's not going full all in
because he knows he's going to get
rejected but watch watch the weirdness
that comes out of this idiot's mouth and
this is less than 100 days from critical
midterm elections the fbi rate of which
donald trump is not on the ballot and
neither is joe biden well the reason
that they're so concerned right now is
because we are less than a hundred days
and right now
you could literally point to anyone who
said yep this is pretty [ __ ] up from
the republican side and we haven't seen
that which means that all of these
people and we talked about it yesterday
with brett they they [ __ ] hitched
their wagon on and they're like we are
so far along on this trail that we
cannot turn around right if we turn
around it is the end of our political
career i mean you see liz cheney right
and her and her uh her re-election she's
going through this but she's like you
know what look if i'm gonna [ __ ]
go out i'm gonna go out guns blazing and
throwing this [ __ ] down
she's like at least i know that my last
son yeah she's like at least i know if i
go down i went down swinging and i made
sure that he was exposed for the fraud
that he is wow and she'll be home she'll
be the leader of the republican party if
they can get their [ __ ] together here
right right
yeah
president trump is a complete abuse and
overreach of its authority
and as the american people know
unfortunately this is the same agency
leadership that protected hillary
clinton james what no continue to
protect hunter biden the same agency
leadership that perpetrated the false
russia hoax for you
and it's not just these national issues
that have led to
historic distrust if you remember he
fired james comey i mean andrew mccain
became the acting fbi director he [ __ ]
not only did he get fire him he made him
lose his goddamn retirement for the time
being i don't know if andrew mccabe has
gotten it back but they fired him like a
month before you remember jeff sessions
kicked him out so he could get his
return and then even jeff sessions was
like up nope i got to recuse myself
right right which is the act which is
nonsense which is crazy to be like oh
yeah jeff sessions like we should
totally uh follow with what he's doing
like if you want to recuse yourself
because i'm too attached
that that was the actual thing following
protocol to be like i'm too too close to
this right now the other thing about his
laptop is the attorney general who was
over the department of justice when they
received the hunter buying laptop was
bill barr not [ __ ] and mayor garcia
the same guy who said the 2020 fraud
election claims were [ __ ] it's on
video
deposition under oath she's such a
[ __ ] liar let's listen oh my god
among the american people it's local
issues as well like in my district the
fbi's leadership overreach and
politicization continues to occur the
fbi continues to stonewall a critical
investigation their stonewalling
providing information and transparency
into their role in the deadliest car
crash in recent years where they
mishandled a long-time fbi informant how
does that have anything to do with
politics she's saying that they're
politicizing something what the [ __ ] are
you talking about she's well she's
trying she's playing what about us she's
like well how do we expect them to
handle this but this is really when they
did it yeah this is really horrible what
about them like they're not doing a good
job like yes it is unfortunate that this
case that she's talking about if there
were people that were injured unfairly
you know or on uh
in a in a manner that was
not right or whatever i don't know the
case that she's referring to but she's
saying it was involving an informant of
the fbi yeah that any any loss of human
life is terrible but the fact that she's
trying to compare and say hey hey hey
why are we talking about this thing we
should really be talking about this
other case about this deadly car crash
involving an fbi informant that's the
real threat to american democracy and
look i know the fbi has a very shitty
past okay
the way they handled martin luther king
jr it was [ __ ] up right but let's
let's try to believe for a moment
that there is some level of sanity and
some level of wanting to
follow justice and law and order
that the fbi would go about
pursuing trump because it actually is
proven
to be done illegally right like they
they got these documents because trump
was holding on to them illegally and he
had taken documents that he did not have
ownership over and now the republican
party is trying to double down and say
this is unfair treatment of trump he
should totally have kept those documents
because he was scrapbooking and i don't
know maybe maybe it was trump or maybe
it was aliens right like the i the fact
that they're throwing these things out
there are are insane what about isms
that are unrelated well you know you
know i've i've heard that bigfoot
actually doesn't live in california
lives in south florida i'm just saying
i actually certainly international
reporters may not know this issue for
reporters in the media in my district
this is one of the most important fbi
issues that we're facing in upstate new
york but the american people are smart
and they have had enough yep it is
why there is a fundamental lack of trust
in these agencies and the american
people agencies
you your party republican majority will
leave no stone unturned when it comes to
transparency and accountability into the
brazen politicization of joe biden's doj
and fbi targeting their political
opponent seeing this is more of this
this dog whistle to
to take control and go to your local fbi
office you're you're biting biting
enforcement agency or whatever the [ __ ]
they're talking about it's just
absolutely ridiculous uh gabe we're
we're running low on time and i know
we're going to do a bonehead of the week
and yeah it was kind of rigged this week
but
i don't know if i would say
very appropriate very appropriate people
voted how they wanted let's find let's
find out how to make three choices
let's find out how rigged it was stick
around bone of the week coming right at
you right after this break
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there is a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day i'm
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
[ __ ] em
[Music]
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
welcome welcome back to the show
it's friday it's second hour
you voted you decided
we're gonna break it down we're gonna
break down your choice
for this week's bone end of the week and
boy did you have a lot of yeah a lot of
choices here and gabe bone end of the
week
of the week
it was quite a week let me tell you well
let me tell you it just kept going along
going along i think there was a lot of
probably a lot of news buried including
um it seems today that the house is
going to pass if they haven't already
the inflation reduction act um that kind
of got news got swept under what rug as
we watched as donald trump has been
exposed as a treasonous spy possibly who
was steering nuclear information from
our government i don't know we'll find
out we'll find out but let's do this
let's get into it bonehead of the week
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this week's edition of
bone-in of the week
we had a great poll we had a great poll
there was three great contestants it was
the it would i could say it might be one
of our best polls yet
best pull ever it's fabulous yeah
tripping
the best many people any people
are saying it was the best poll ever we
had three great candidates now we've
been waiting for a long time we've
talked about doing this for a long time
where we just put one person on the pole
it never seemed appropriate until this
week
but our three contestants this week
were donald trump the cheeto dust
mobster and grandpa poopy pants himself
so these three candidates deserve uh
great accolades for being on this poll
for bonehead of the week
so where where where shall we start with
these three contestants for bonehead of
the week
it really is it was all week and let's
let's go
let's not let's not get away from the
elephant in the room donald trump
absolutely [ __ ] himself in every way
every which fashion dude there was
ketchup all over the walls it looked
like a [ __ ] jackson pollock at
mar-a-lago guaranteed well let's catch
up on this week's bone end of the week
so where are we going to start first
because i think we should start with uh
this search warrant or the raid as as
some people are calling it some people
are scared to call it a raid i'm not
really scared to call it a raid i think
search warrant raid whatever you want to
call it i believe that the look and the
the feel of this is not going to change
in the american you know the american
political body and how they're
discussing this um i've even i even my
16 year old son actually mentioned that
he saw on one of his social media sites
that he's on that there was a video of
donald trump talking about how the mob
pleads the fifth and then he played the
fifth he's like that's crazy which it
he's like politics never leaks into my
thread and it leaked into my thread yeah
so people are paying attention this
people are paying attention this week
and we'll get to the fifth thing here
soon yeah yeah but the first part of the
week the really the search warrant and
the raid but more than that because we
talked about this before and i've said
this the rate is important
the search warrant the issuing of the
search warrant and the execution was
important but more importantly
more importantly i believe that the
uh the thing that was most that was
that was the hilarious part of it is the
right wing reacting to this in real time
it was [ __ ] fantastic tucker carlson
even hasn't even been on his show all
week he was i guess he's still changing
his diapers
you know some might ask you know where
in the world is tucker carlson uh
because it seems a little suspect that
all of a sudden when this raid happens
not saying that they're connected but
when you know mar-a-lago gets searched
by the fbi
tucker carlson is
not in you have that video of tucker
carlson that night um during the raid
where um uh tucker carlson um light
comes on our wish.com tucker carlson
comes on air that would be a great clip
to show here because um that that just
shows in that moment the absolute freak
out
of
of uh fox news and the late night fox
news the prime times host
tucker carlson and the like let me uh
let me if you've got that yeah i'll
search for that video but they
absolutely freaked out they were all
freaking out even marjorie tater green
was freaking out um
of course trump on on fraud social has
been freaking out oh yeah
he has been uh [ __ ] himself
100
right
all all week it's in and really that
stems from this raid but we also see
this week with this bonehead um the
fifth amendment which we're going to
we're really going to get to here did
you find
well let me play this clip while you're
waiting because um i think this is
hilarious um this is a reaction from a
trump supporter we played it earlier in
the week but boy it really does um
feels like this was ages ago that we
watched this person with this really
huge foam hat and talk about how it's an
injustice that a criminal would be would
be raided by the fbi after committing
crimes let's watch an administration the
democrats are weaponizing the fbi and it
has to stop
the fbi is not here to weaponize against
another president it never has happened
before um they should go after things
that are clearly a violation meaning the
hunter laptop which they don't even have
to investigate because the laptop is
right there
so here you have the trump supporter
outside with a really weird ass hat um
apparently these hats are available
online if you'd like to get one a
dumbass hat from the conservative comedy
store
yeah well comedy
okay so it is hilarious though that
these hats are real that's a funny thing
now here's the thing about this clip and
about what she's talking about because
what they're saying what the trump
supporters the mogalodites the internet
trolls the [ __ ] gr the people being
grifted by the grifter-in-chief what
they're saying is oh my god i can't
believe joe biden is politicizing and
weaponizing the doj and the fbi like
donald trump said he would right
literally that is whether we should have
done that lock her up and get rid of
that we need to lock hunter biden and
joe biden in jail like they're calling
for all these people to be sent down to
gitmo and hanged
out
they will talk they will project their
own because this is the worry right the
worry is that
the worst thing possible is true right
these claims of classified documents
nuclear codes nuclear nuclear codes
sorry
uh were
were at trump's fingertips right and
mar-a-lago is not that safe when
somebody uh earlier this year was able
to steal
devices she was sentenced to eight uh
eight months in prison i think seven
months in prison but
it's not secure it there are definitely
holes in security and where people can
access and it's a place where if you're
a president you would not
think to
you know if you were of sound mind and
body which trump is clearly not uh you
would you would think yeah yeah you know
what these aren't my documents and i
definitely shouldn't keep it here at a
residence slash a public or private club
where people can come in and out right
and i have events at weddings this and
that i have to jump
he split a special lock where it was
come on and you know what you know what
made me think of and i said this earlier
what it made me think of trump buying a
special lock you know the little the
kids diaries and it has the little hard
lock rocket yeah a little heart lock it
on that that's what i envisioned like he
put that was the lock that he used as
some kind of like
trinket locket
like i wouldn't i wouldn't be surprised
if that was the thing like he's like hey
you want it to my safe and it was a
piggy bank or something like you know
something so childish you know where he
was like they broke into my safe well
here's wish.com tucker carlson that
evening um as the mogul of the nights
were descending on uh palm beach island
there in florida his his daughter-in-law
goes on uh tucker carlson's white
privilege tonight uh but tucker wasn't
there it was wish.com tucker it was
tucker with the facelift um he asked
laura why why would they raid this place
laura uh you've spoken to your
father-in-law um therefore you have the
most immediate information of anybody
we've spoken with tonight
do does he know do you he definitely
would not lie to you yeah
like what are you talking about what the
hell are you talking about of course he
would lie to her i mean over and over
and over again but let's listen i do
know why his home was rated
he believes it's the documents in
question that uh you know everybody's
been really upset about from the white
house look my father in lies anybody
knows who's been around him a lot loves
to say things like newspaper clippings
magazine clippings uh photographs
documents that he had every authority
will to take from the white house which
you don't need and it's not true if
there was ever a wrong answer that is it
it's all [ __ ] we talked about this
yesterday because there's this there he
keeps bringing up
a guy named hugh sane who's taking
presidential documents to chicago and he
fails to mention that in chicago where
those documents are going is a [ __ ]
presidential library who is being
operated under the authority of national
archives and the national archives are
the ones taking those documents there
now
when you leave the white house there is
from what i understand there is a
certain procedure
that you go through if you want to take
property of the government with you and
you can have custody of it it doesn't
mean it's yours
it is still the property of the
government is still part of the
presidential archive but they will give
you a pro there's a protocol to get
permission for those pieces of the
archive to leave and be in your custody
for the time being they do the same
thing gabe when they want a piece of the
presidential archive to be moved
somewhere else into the custody of
someone else if there is a procedure for
the custody and it is done that way and
we talked about it yeah well we've been
talking about it all week that this idea
that that
that donald trump is going to get a
presidential library frankly is
ridiculous unless it's a coloring book
factory but the thing is is the national
archive is a [ __ ] federal building
ran by the federal government us it has
given funding by us the federal
government to house those documents
that's the whole point is to make sure
that we the people we the government
have an archive of our office the office
of the presidency when whoever's name is
on the building was holding that office
it really is not that complicated and i
actually think that donald trump
um not only has is probably going to be
charged with crimes here with whatever
whatever the crime is that they're going
to find that he committed with these
documents um but also it's really going
to hurt his chances of ever receiving an
actual presidential library somewhere
they will probably hold his office's uh
records in the actual our archives in
washington dc there were i hope i i
really hope there's never a [ __ ]
building that's branded by his name i
mean i would his name in library right i
mean like
if you were to give that guy with
we know you having or using the
precedent that is set right now which is
this guy took documents and even after
he said we gave all the documents if we
had him we'd give him to the government
turns out he was lying and had almost
double the amount of documents whether
the copies or additional
documents
uh he was still holding on to and that's
why the fbi came to search his home
now
which again was signed off by
christopher wray the fbi director
republican that he appointed right that
he put in that position
also
uh
you've got the the judge right which is
uh bruce rinehart he's a republican
judge down in florida right and then
you've got uh merrick garland like all
of these people were attached to it and
they they said yep we should do it okay
cool i'll sign out from the fbi and then
you've got a judge down in florida who
said
well i mean everything seems to check
out here this is a reasonable concern
that a president is still holding on to
classified documents
because they also they they are privy to
whatever the search warrant was the
thing that trump said release you know
i'll release the search warrant which
you know you and i both don't believe he
will
but
that's the thing these people have seen
it and go yeah the evidence looks pretty
[ __ ] damning like i can't i can't not
sign it right i have to sign this
because if i do
then it would show that it is i am
deciding a political side
and that's you know
keep in mind that all the people that
were in play here were either people
appointed by president trump or
republicans or it's coming all the way
up from the top which is you know
merrick garland saying yeah we should
look into this right for all the people
that were like why isn't you know
mayor garland doing something quick
enough why go after trump it's like
turns out
there was some pretty big [ __ ] going on
and it was it like the idea that we
thought january 6th was the craziest
thing
and then we find out and we had joked
for years during his presidency for his
first term because he's a one-term
president
that he had his finger on the nuclear
codes right on the nuclear button at any
point he was going to nuke that
hurricane down in florida
he was going to send he's going to send
missiles into mexico
exactly and so you look at this and
you're like oh man we were kind of
joking like the guy was is not totally
stable right he's not the stable genius
that everyone says he is
and so he's the only one that says that
right you know i'm the stable genius or
whatever yeah man woman person camera tv
right like that's the guy who's like i
can remember these words
like great uh for you uh but
but you've got this guy that you're like
yeah he is a
someone to be concerned about right so
the idea that he would actually get a
library to hold on to documents that are
classified or that are secure
he would definitely try to you know he's
like
the back door in here but that's the
thing is a lot of people let that's the
that's the argument here is that he's
not went through the proper protocol for
those documents that were in the 15
boxes and the 12 boxes uh you know
following
and he he probably did not follow the
protocol for any of that stuff and the
reason why is because he wouldn't obtain
it and took it with him if he had
followed that protocol now
in a presidential library it's not like
the president can just walk in and take
whatever he wants
that's not how it works that is a
federal building with their name on it
we fund it the national archive runs it
and that's why this nonsense about obama
and all this [ __ ] is just ridiculous
right but uh speaking of ridiculous
here's jesse water and dan bongino's
almost immediate reaction and this is
one of the best this is not a laughing
matter tony right it's not funny damn it
uh it's hilarious actually yeah but and
danbongino points out how hilarious it
is let's listen
i just want to say in closing
listen america they're laughing at you
the left thinks this is hilarious if you
doubt me just go to any of their
platforms twitter or elsewhere right now
they think this we're laughing at
ourselves hilarious
you know what
so gabe and i i think i can find it here
probably but there was also a video
speaking of laughing huh and they think
it's funny there was actually a [ __ ]
airplane that they paid oh yeah to go
over to go over the uh to go over
mar-a-lago and fly and i think we should
just everyone should donate to have this
plane just constantly you know as long
as it's light outside have this [ __ ]
plane be flying over mar-a-lago
it was a big banner said
for for the people out there who say uh
is this the one guy that you sent me
i'm going to send you the one right now
that is yeah i got i got it right here i
got it okay cool um so here is here's
the um
here's the
the the video of the plane
cut the sound here but you see you see
it says hahahahaha the banner just it
just says ha ha ha ha ha because they
are like we are laughing at you we are
laughing at you because we and and the
thing is we told you boneheads this we
told you this that this was not going to
go in your favor not just making him the
president not just making the lead of
the party but continuing this nonsense
after what happened on january 6 and
after he left the office of the
presidency we told you this stupid [ __ ]
was gonna happen yeah um let's go to a
video that you have here um of lindsey
graham and then i want to get to the
fifth amendment stuff because i know you
made a video on the fifth amendment
thing so i want to get to that real
quick um because that was also another
boneheaded thing this week but this is
again jesse waters interviewing lindsey
graham i gotta say jesse waters there
was a there was a part in my brain i was
like did jesse waters get on the list
this week because if there was any like
any trump stan
that this week that was using his
platform or their platform for
uh to push disinformation about what the
search warrant was for what this oh it
was jesse for sure it was just because
it wasn't just on this show is on the
five cause any on the five two
yeah yeah yeah well that's all yeah
that's yeah is it all the same or is it
uh let me well there's also the five
clip that i'm thinking of right now let
me let me go okay let me play this one
having you on lindsay you know you and i
have debated about things and i've seen
you pretty spitting mad over ukraine
but you you don't seem as mad as you
were about this then you've been mad
about ukraine i don't understand why
people aren't lighting their hair on
fire i don't understand why people
aren't out in the streets because he
committed crimes let's just see what's
in the war just jesse jesse waters like
get out in the streets and start
committing violence damn it why aren't
you doing that yet
they've been doing this this is the
third election
this is the third election we know they
doctor evidence we know they plant
evidence
we know they hide evidence we know they
lie we know they leak
there's lindsey graham saying that the
fbi plants evidence
a sitting united states senator
who claims to bla back the blue and he's
claiming that the fbi is planning
evidence get the [ __ ] out of here man
these people sunk to a whole new low
they won't stop um it's just ridiculous
i want to go to uh who the uh because we
got we got an alpha cuck and we've got a
dishonorable mention this year too you
know we do the alpha kick and
dishonorable mention so gabe who is the
alpha cuck this week let's find out
wow well
i told him i told my interns to find the
worst person to be
whoever got cocked the worst yeah put
them on why did he get i think he got
cucked for this fifth amendment thing
that's is that why you put him on the
couch yeah yeah yeah he totally got cut
100
was an alpha cuck this week because he
said in the past
only the mob takes the fifth why would
you take them why would you plead the
fifth if you're innocent right like all
these questions of like
uh
himself he cucked himself
because then we find out because tisch
james is like yeah [ __ ] this guy right
and they were like oh yeah i was there
when he was pleading the fifth
in new york this week well yes she she
was in the room and she was asking him
questions um
now
there is some um
i don't know how long it was but it was
apparent that he was gonna you know plea
the fifth the entire time like he wasn't
gonna he wasn't gonna stop doing that um
and i'm trying to find this video of
yours that you had uh put out on the on
him though
uh
on him saying yeah the mob pleads the
fifth because i like that video i
actually put it in the um the version of
my rant now here it is i've got it um
of the uh
the video i sent over that's on the
minus touch network's youtube channel
but here is here is uh trump loves the
fifth he loves it he loves saying it
even yeah
when you have
your staff
taking the fifth amendment yeah taking
the fifth
what's funny about this one is this is
where he's in a debate with hillary yeah
yeah so this is this is also during the
series of debates where hillary was like
if this guy becomes [ __ ] president
this is how it's going to go right right
right what you're watching is what you
will continue to watch and like no he'll
surely change and be president yeah he
won't be that bad and then it was like
everything she said it was like yep she
was
she was even warning you about the
nuclear codes the nuclear the [ __ ] the
nuclear
she is
you know i'm not saying she's like uh
a suit sayer you know or like uh someone
who can predict the future but she is
on the money this is like us predicting
stuff and you know i said doubt me it's
really not that difficult yeah i know i
know i mean like she understands the
pattern that trump has and what he does
and so it would totally make sense
that he would continue to do that
especially if he's given even more power
right the guy's a [ __ ] egomaniac and
well i mean he's the king he's the king
of being predictably unpredictable right
yeah yeah that's the whole thing like
that's that's that's trump is like that
he did was surprising
and kind of unsurprising at the same
time right right but in the end well i
mean it's shocking but it's not
surprising right it's shocking that that
would happen
he had the nuclear codes
that's that's crazy and that's shocking
but like um
i could have totally seen that coming
let's let's finish here so they're not
prosecuted i think it's disgraceful if
you're not guilty of a crime what do you
need immunity for pleading the fifth
amendment pleading the fifth amendment
taking the fifth amendment the fifth
amendment in the fifth amendment fifth
amendment fifth amendment fifth
amendment horrible
do you think do you think that's
actually how he was in like with james
like she would go to say something like
fifth amendment yeah fifth amendment
fifth amendment fifth amendment he was
that's what he also said it was fifth
amendment but then i think uh
i think i saw something about him not
even saying fifth amendment at one point
he just said
same answer as previous or same answer
as before
uh which is like wow you can't even say
fifth amendment you have to go like yeah
i just said that i just said which which
in his standards that's pretty that's
pretty low he can't even say the same
thing over and over again that's pretty
low which which i'm like is that legally
allowed i don't know but it seems weird
it's like which
you said you plead the fifth and then
you're like oh it you know like the same
as the previous answer which is like you
didn't actually say you plead the fifth
you just said like the other one which i
i don't know like again i'm no lawyer i
don't know how that works but the idea
that you can just be like
saying you know
i'm using the same as my previous answer
whatever seems
longer in roundabout way of just saying
uh the fifth the fifth well
so um ben meizelos of legal af did a
video on the midas touch uh network
about pleading the fifth and and they
talked about it um also i believe last
night on the mind and such uh podcast um
he was talking about how
like in a criminal trial when you're
you're on a criminal indictment and you
use the fifth to not self-incriminate
yourself like they can't use they can't
use that you use the fifth against you
right so
if they ask you a question you plea the
fifth the the prosecution in that sense
can't use that against you in court
right because you are you are using that
amendment to crim incriminate not to
incriminate yourself
but in a civic or a civil trial so this
is a civil trial that the state of new
york is placing on the trump
organization in a civil trial it's not
the same way because you're not you
can't incriminate yourself in a civil
trial uh yeah yeah i'm sorry i have some
breaking news related related to this to
the fifth amendment no no it's about the
only so we can go through the fifth
amendment but i've got breaking news
that relates to what was what was
searched for oh well let's go to that
let's go that we we rarely have breaking
news on the bonehead of the week i like
this breaking news on bone end of the
week about the bonehead of the week um
looks like spiro agnew's ghost is um
tweeting here breaking from wall street
journal fbi agents who searched donald
trump's mar-a-lago home monday removed
11 sets oh [ __ ] i'm classified documents
11 sets of clock in classified i i take
that as um maybe one box a piece that
may be where the 12 boxes is coming in
yeah it's possible yeah i'm just i'm
just pointing that out um including some
marked as top secret and meant to be
only available in special government
facilities holy [ __ ] this guy has skiff
documents yeah holy [ __ ] so this guy has
these documents that are only allowed to
be in skiffs because that's the other
thing about even like a presidential
library there's part of the presidential
archive that never actually makes it to
the presidential library because it
can't be in that room because there's
not secure enough facilities yeah in
that in that building well also so for
people who also know like if anyone
doesn't know what a skiff is it's
basically like a secret
sensitive compartmented information what
is it
compartmented information facility okay
so basically you're like in an
undisclosed location
uh you know a white room essentially
where nothing is tapped in you don't
have any line out like it is a there is
no way for anyone to penetrate right
they they won't allow you to bring like
cameras in or yeah yeah it's your you
it's basically what happens when like a
director like christopher nolan says hey
you can come
to
um this location
and you can read this script there's
only one copy you can read this script
no phones nothing is allowed in here you
can take as much time as you need to
read it
but the other idea too is that like a
skip is somewhere
where it's you know these are these are
areas that you wouldn't typically know
of you know they're
they're out and about and only the
military or national security defenses
would actually know the locations right
because if you give away a skiff then
you're like oh well you know someone
could plan an attack or something but
yeah it's basically going into an area
where nobody knows about uh because it's
for national security uh
issues right
and having a room that is completely
sealed off from anything else no
electronics no no recording
so they can actually view this material
in private as private as you can get
and so the fact that
these documents were supposed to only be
in places like that like i don't even
know how you walk out of a place like
that you know or like how you can get
your hands on those documents well i
mean because they would be in a skiff in
the white house he probably lifted them
from the skiff in a white house this guy
was known to eat documents flush
documents there's no but i'm surprised
that you wouldn't even stuff it in this
diaper even if stuffing in his diaper
and walk out i mean yeah i mean like i
was surprised like even if you were in a
skiff room inside the white house right
or anywhere else yeah but this guy was
known to break the rules and everyone
just stand back and go well he's the
president what are we going to do right
which brings me to my dishonorable
mention of the week gabe we have a
dishonorable mention this week too as we
do every week
oh
we should have we should have the sound
effect boom
boom dishonorable mention is donald
trump i believe that he's the
dishonorable mention this week i want to
believe it's because he keeps stoking
now this this underlying terrorism and
um and his allies are doing the exact
same thing i want to show you here
patriotic points out uh ali alexander
he's a he's a insurrectionist he's in
treasonous insurrections he was planning
the attack on our democracy
um and he points it out well here stop
the steel founder ally alexander wants
his followers to disclaim non-violence
and quotes warns were in final stages of
the coup against american people so i'm
not i think this is projection
like this is projection well yeah but
here is here is his statement on
this is telegram right yep
this is telegram um
he says this is what ally alexander says
biden approved
garland authorized rey executed right
which
one of those things is not true okay um
we're in the final stages of the coup
against the american people which that
seems that statement there seems like
projection to me
like hey folks we're almost there kind
of thing not like well we also know that
uh ali alexander has a tendency to try
to be
uh
the
center of attention right whether it's
um
you know he he he was making he was
inferring that he was going to be the
secret witness right
um
uh for the january 6th committee because
everyone's like oh man who was it going
to be who's it going to be and then he
was posting on telegram another place to
be like oh i've been asked to like you
know you know i got to come into dc now
and so like you know he's he's hanging
out with the likes of alex jones you
know uh they were down in june domestic
terrorists exactly they were down in
georgia you know and they actually on
camera discuss like what they had to do
in order to actually be successful right
um
well he goes on to say here in this
telegram if that's what you call it uh
ba patrick henry and warn other patriots
and he puts in here disclaim
non-violence where and when necessary
so what he's saying is make a disclaimer
that you want non-violence
make sure there's the disclaimer there
even though that's not what you want
that's what he's saying here that's what
he's that's what he's it's what he's
saying that's what he's saying that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and traitor hey i
don't understand why this guy isn't
[ __ ] locked up to be quite honest
with you right um i think he's dangerous
as [ __ ] but uh it just goes to show you
because um i looked here
one of uh midas touch
um one of the mizellas brothers posted
just a bit ago i think about an hour ago
now speaking of domestic terrorism and
threats
now brett mizella supposed to this
dude let me see if i can find it he
posted a picture of a letter that was
sent to an old midas touch address i
guess um is what this is if i can find
it man damn where i just i just had it i
just had it damn you
let me find it um but brett posted a
letter that was sent to an old minus
touch
address here it is um and he said today
i learned
well let's see today i learned a
threatening letter was sent to midas
touch the letter was sent to a location
where we no longer live or work and
contains a violent threat to shoot up a
school holy [ __ ] we have reported this
to federal authorities and
and law enforcement um who are
investigating so here is of course they
hide the address but there is uh there's
a threat since the minus touch
um obviously
they don't like hearing us say what
we're saying
um and they are not gonna they're not
gonna quit this kind of stuff this kind
of garbage um so everyone you know stay
safe out there i know i know it feels
like this won't bubble over but we
watched it bubble over in cincinnati and
i believe that's why he gets
dishonorable mention is because
they're not just him but the republican
party and his little his little
magledites right out there uh inside
congress and on the media the far the
far-right media are doing everything
they can to try to stoke violence as we
as we saw in cincinnati um yesterday
you know there was there was someone
else on my list that i was potentially
considering this week
uh for dishonorable mention
no for the alpha [ __ ] oh okay who is
that was that don winslow uh oh
oh yes you're talking about you're
talking about the guy who who if you
listen which we didn't listen to a lot
of the tape but if you go back and
listen to the domestic terrorist press
conference this morning in the house
where those domestic terrorists were
trying to justify someone stealing
documents and blaming merrick garland
and merrick gardens the enemy the fbi
the doj's enemy it's all their fault
they're to blame and they need to be
arrested they need to be investigated
they are using the same language that
don winslow was using
um for a long and has been using for a
long time and i'm not scared to go after
him everyone said that i was going after
the left i'm not going after the left
i'm going after someone who's got a very
big a very big account a very big a very
big megaphone and they're saying they're
kicking democracy when they're down
because when i posted something against
him on the podcast account
because he's blocked me on my personal
and i can show it here and i mean i the
other thing too is like he yesterday he
had a tweet that was like the last year
and a half right they've been they've
been sitting with the knowledge that he
had this like one
we don't know right they knew that he
had these things for a year and a half
right they might have had an idea and
they were going through other people
they might have been investigating and
trying to be like where did the
documents go who had clearance who had
access going through those people to be
like
don't have it don't have it don't have
it don't have it
all right well the last one on the list
is donald trump right like also keep in
mind
that for the last year and a half don
winzo like i think that he has a a big
platform and you know he he is able to
help
fund
smart yeah
can be an effective tool for the left
100
he has the money and the resources and
he has said he was retiring from writing
and he was going to help fund other
people create videos and other content
for the left you just i don't know
what's what's in the process or what's
working but if that actually is actually
happening i think that could be very
effective to have him be the powerful
like bulldozing force to go through
and shine light on these other smaller
creators up and coming people
to to bring awareness around these
illegal acts that are happening so he
for the last year and i was like garland
has to do his job why isn't he acting
why isn't he acting he's got to go act
quicker right you've got all these memes
of uh
of chris farley on the snl schedule man
living down by the motivational speaker
like down by the river and it's a meme
that says merrick garland you know like
do your job
and for he for the last year and a half
he's just been complaining about this
and then as soon
as the doj merrick garland come forward
and say hey look so yeah like we noticed
that everyone has been saying do our job
and we have been
because during that time we were
investigating
him and all of the parties like this
isn't just again this is somebody's like
rush and jump over and be like hey let
me get those documents back or you know
like again they had to investigate and
figure out who had them and at the time
to make sure they had the evidence to
prove
that they could get a search warrant
they could go into his home and they
could you know legally go about
searching it and not make it seem like
it was a political
act against trump it's just a criminal
act against trump because he is a serial
criminal
well again again and i pointed this out
i said did merrick garland steal your
lunch money a long time ago or some [ __ ]
you're a coward and a grifter and i hope
you're following sees you who for who
you really are now um he blocked me so
you couldn't see us but i took a
screenshot um
because he didn't block me from the pod
account which he probably will or has
already so i took a screenshot from
there and says so the fb here's it was
this quote so the fbi doj let quote
nuclear documents sit at donald trump's
home for a year and a half and people
are praising them instead of asking how
could you possibly let top secret
documents be at trump's home for a year
and a half that's the whole point why
they went there don dummy and the story
is why did doj fbi take so long this is
so stupid he absolutely has dug his
heels in so much of his this narrative
that the doj and the and merrick garland
and the united states government is not
going to prosecute trump that he cannot
see the forest through the trees and don
i implore you see the force through the
trees stop writing this [ __ ] stop
posting this ship stop grifting your
followers to think that something
nefarious is going on at the department
of justice it's not the department of
justice it's not the fbi it's not
merrick garland donald trump is the
criminal he's the one that's going to be
held accountable for this we are seeing
it live and in person not just in the
doj and the department of justice are
the merrick gardens office and the fbi
we're seeing it in in the select
committee so stop with the nonsense stop
with the [ __ ] and anyone following
this guy if you like him fine
like you said i think don can be an
effective tool but he's not being he's
kicking he's kicking democracy while
it's down and someone even we've invited
him on the show we love him
and i'll talk to him about it i'll let
him explain himself
probably not to his
great desire of how i would do it but i
would let him explain himself but here's
the thing here's what i want to say
about this because someone said that
they had doubts themselves and i said
there's nothing wrong with doubt doubt
is different than kicking democracy
while they're down this is well past don
winslow's doubt and his possibility to
doubt right so doubt me doubt me
you know we're gonna make some t-shirts
i guess um let's go let's go to the
winner of the bone in the week game who
is the winner in our contestants here we
had some great contestants wow the
winner is donald trump you know i did
not see that happening
couldn't even guess that couldn't even
guess that well i think i think we
should just give the winner his due here
because everyone knows exactly he's a
traitor he's he's a spy he sells our
secrets i just want to say that this is
the first time we've had one person just
sweep in all categories i know all of
them and
it is it is very it is very fitting that
it was him let's give let's give the
winner a bone end of the week his due
here we go
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
never in the history of bone ended a
week have we had one person get 100 of
the vote
but we we did it this week one person
got a hundred percent of the vote and
it's very fitting that that one person i
we've rigged it we [ __ ] rigged it
let's just say it we rigged it well and
again we've been wanting to rig one for
a while because everyone's like whoa why
don't you put in all of the above we're
like well that would rig it to all the
above like every time and then we
wouldn't have a winner so i wanted to
see which one would get the most answers
i was like yeah i could put one on there
and it'd be a hundred percent
but i also wanted to see what would
happen if we put
all three as an option as the same
person i just wanted to see kind of
where it would lay out i mean of course
the first one on the list is going to be
the biggest one and it just went down
from there but i was surprised that
actual people were like yeah you know
what i'm gonna go with option two donald
trump and somebody were like i'm gonna
go with option three donald trump well
maybe they were maybe they were talking
about the donald trump that played the
fifth right maybe that's what we should
have done donald trump um raided donald
trump oh yeah the fifth and then donald
trump nuclear documents maybe yeah maybe
we should have been more specific yeah
yeah yeah well and then we would have no
well there's going to be a next time
with this guy probably and he's really
the only person that could probably
manage to be all three and make it worth
its wild for them all three for us to
rig it one week because you guys love
phone in the week we love bone of the
week don't forget uh to to go to twitter
follow tony michael's pod you can vote
there every single week for bone in a
week and you you also need to subscribe
right here on youtube do not forget to
hit that subscribe button so you can
vote here on youtube as well
for bonehead of the week
and it's every single friday in the
second hour and we even cut it out and
we download it on all your favorite
podcast
directories apple spotify google your
favorite ones while you're there
downloading bone in the week on sundays
cause that's when we put it there on
sundays don't forget to leave us a great
review this has been this week's edition
of boneheaded week stick around we have
a few announcements right after the song
[Music]
[Applause]
boom boom
i do want to say quick announcement i
saw some people that were asking about
the t-shirt so i've which one the doubt
doubt me no
yes the doubt me is something we're
working on
i saw people asking about the defund mtg
oh
i just put the the link in yeah we'll
pull up i think you got it penned right
yeah so here is the um here's the here's
the here's the defund mtg shop now
that's what it looks like and here's the
tweet it's penned to the top of gabe's
profile um it gives you the link and
everything there so you just go to
gabe sanchez's profile
on twitter you can find a link there
to find those
defund
mtg did you see that she has an uh a
hatchimal that says fbi and you can't
even read it like it just looks like it
says fbi oh yeah i was debating i was
like should i make a hat and i was like
would people actually wear a hat but
also it's such small real estate so then
you have to like see it as opposed to
the shirt which is what i would say
right you have a main billboard seat you
would see it well we appreciate all the
new listeners here remember every single
weekday we broadcast live from youtube
twitter and twitch two full hours noon
eastern 11 central nine pacific and we
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page don't forget to hit subscribe here
on the tony michaels podcast youtube
channel you don't want to miss a thing
and also go over and follow us on
twitter tony michael's pod don't forget
to vote every week for bone end of the
week and download bone end of the week
every single sunday also game on
saturday we do a best of so tomorrow you
can download an episode of best of
tomorrow
tomorrow and actually you know what we
had a clip that didn't work when we sent
it i think i'm going to use that
i think i'm going to use that for best
of tomorrow it's an it's a
never-before-seen clip remember it's
about the raid it was oh
i think i'm going to use that clip so
it's a never tomorrow for the best of
bonus content
never before seen clip yeah
breaking down the raid exclusive
exclusive so don't miss it tomorrow best
of the week you can watch it on youtube
you can listen to it on your favorite
podcast don't forget when you go over
and listen to give us a great review
over there and subscribe to our podcast
it helps us out over there on the
directories even if you watch it and you
want to list it you can do both you can
go over to directory you can subscribe
you can leave a review you can hit play
on some of those on some of those
episodes maybe you want to catch your
favorite part whatever part it is you
can go fast forward and find your
favorite part and listen to it over
there while you're running exercising
maybe you're cooking maybe you're doing
all sorts of things that you want to
listen to the tony michaels podcast and
on the directory so do that do that
everyone have a great weekend
i can't wait to see you on monday we're
probably going to have big news this
afternoon it's going to be a big a big
huge episode on monday at noon eastern
11 central nine pacific do not want to
miss that one tune in youtube twitter
twitch
live also simulcasting from the minus
touch facebook page have a safe and
great weekend until monday
surf's up
[ __ ] you've been listening to
the tony michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking